The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I was
at Atlanta yesterday
attending a conference.
I met an expert from
the disk drive industry.
I know her well.
And you remember
I was just saying
that the diskette and separation
is below 10 nanometers.
Do you know how much
what's a separation now?
AUDIENCE: One [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Let's just
say about 1.5 nanometers.
So that's what everybody
has in the computer.
It's amazing technology.
AUDIENCE: So we could
just go for solid state.
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: We could just go
for solid state [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Where [? you ?]
how [INAUDIBLE] you
can push, right?
But this was actually
a lab-mate of mine,
and she worked on
nanoscale heat transfer.
And see, that's a perfect place
because what they're doing is
the magnetic-- when you
make it a very small domain,
you actually cannot use a
[? normal ?] magnetic field
to flip the magnetic
domain because, otherwise,
the room temperature just
a spontaneous flips back.
So they have to use very hard
magnet, and in that case,
they have to heat up the domain.
So they have to heat up a
nano domain first and then
apply magnetic field to right.
So I thought I'd share
this story with you.
I'll talk a little bit
more about that technology
later on as we learn.
So coming back to last
lecture, what we talked
is a reciprocal space.
That's a continuation and
proved the broad condition.
And that's the, say, when you
do a transmission electron
microscope or you do an
X-ray, broad condition
is the one when you look
at diffraction patterns.
And then we moved on
to discuss the energy
of the atomic
vibration in crystals.
And so we introduce
the phonons, right?
That's just the, say, we
solve the Newton second law.
So first, it's a
continuum approach--
it's a classic approach.
But trading the
atoms as discrete.
And we got the dispersion
between the vibrational
frequency and wave vector.
And the wave vector is similarly
as in the case of electron,
are discretized.
If I have [? any ?] atoms in the
chain, and I have 2 pi over n,
the separation is 2 pi over
the length of the crystal.
n times a is the length
of the crystal, right?
And we have acoustic branch.
And if I have more than one
atom at the lattice point,
I have also
[? optical ?] branch.
And the acoustic branch has a
longitudinal and transverse.
Typically, longitudinal
has a higher frequency
and transfers lower frequency.
And in the case of [? optical ?]
phonon, this sometimes
it can cross over.
So it's hard to say which
one has a higher and lower.
But I think if you deal
with the polar crystal,
like sodium chloride, and
you have always a transverse
phonon lower and the
longitudinal phonon,
[? optical ?] phonon
higher frequency.
So what's important later on
is we'll simplify our models.
And one way to
simplify is the Debye.
So we [? try ?] this here.
Although, the
[? zoom ?] boundary,
you can say we're careful
in drawing this almost
like a perpendicular.
But say, one
approximation we use
is [? approximated ?]
by a straight line.
That's Debye model.
And the other is what
original Einstein proposed
is just a constant frequency.
That's an Einstein model.
And you can see that
Einstein model is closer
for the [INAUDIBLE]
phonons, but Debye model
is closer for the
acoustical phonons.
So that's where we were.
And with that, if
you recall, what
we have talked to so
far, very fast, right,
we talked about energy levels,
first in isolated atoms
and molecules.
And that's vibrational,
translational,
and electronic rotational.
And then we extend
to crystals, and we
say the best treatment
[INAUDIBLE] is one dimension.
And then we say, OK, if you
look at the three dimension,
each direction has
different pure density
and different potential.
So your curve may
look different, right?
And with that, I hope you get
appreciation for the energy
levels of electrons in solid.
With that, you
can understand why
there is the insulator, why
there are semiconductor,
why there are metals, right?
And also, you can now also
have some appreciation
for the large
vibration, the phonons,
which is essentially here
we do a classical treatment.
But what phonon is a quantized
form of this frequency.
At each frequency for that mode,
you cannot have any energy.
You can only have
discrete number of phonon.
The energy is
quantized, all right?
So this gives us
some picture, what
are the quantum mechanical
allowable energy emitters?
And where we're going to
move is to add temperature
because this is a quantum
mechanical allowable.
Now, if I have an object
at a certain temperature,
what's the statistically
average, right?
And really, what's the
energy this object has?
So that's where we're moving.
But before that, I want to
discuss a little bit more
of the content, right?
And if you recall, I said,
I emphasize degeneracy.
A quantum state,
right, quantum state
is defined by, in
the case of waves,
is if I have wave
function in, let's
say I have my wave
function, and kx ky, kz.
Each of this kx, ky, kz,
so here, for example,
in one direction I have discrete
number of k values, right?
Each combination of k value
gives me one specific wave,
of wave function, right?
One wave function is, if I
don't consider spin, right,
electron I have to say one wave
function because of the wave
function itself
doesn't include spin.
So that's one quantum state, OK?
And in the case
of discrete atoms,
we say quantum numbers, right?
If you recall, when we
do electronic states,
we have nlm, right?
That's the quantum number.
And we emphasize the
quant-- because it's
a different combination
of nlm could actually
have the same energy.
That's where we
say this is how you
start understand the periodic
table, right, the degeneracy.
Now, if you look at solid, I'm
only drawing in one direction,
but we know that the
real crystal solid
is three directions.
And now, if I count certain
frequency or certain energy--
if you think about either
frequency or energy
because [? H omega ?] gives
me some energy, right?
And even in the same
direction, you can see here
I have three states,
three wave vectors
that can have same quantum
state, right, same energy.
Three wave vectors, three
quantum [? state can ?]
have same energy.
But if I look at the
other directions,
many, many other
directions, I would
have many other
possible states that
could have the same energy.
So that's the
degeneracy, and that's
where I have to learn how
to do the counting, OK?
So this is a major
emphasis today.
It's the idea of counting.
Today we're really doing
the density of states.
And then when I
say states, I say
this is like density
of quantum states, OK?
And I also hope, at
the end, I have--
with that I'll get into
quantum statistics.
So this is my plan
today, and let's start--
we have looked at a very
complicated band structure
for electrons, for phonons.
This is like going
to the Google,
and you look at all those
different images, right?
But say, for the
analytical purpose,
we're going to look
at the simplest model,
like the Debye model.
And for electrons,
we also say, if it's
at the minimum of
the conduction band
or the maximum of
the valence band,
we [? expend ?] that near
the minimum, maximum, right?
So we have parabolic bands.
So we need this--
So if you'll recall for
electrons approximation,
and in the simplest
picture, this is my k.
And k, you can think
is a kx, ky, kz.
And here is my
conduction band, and I
write this the minimum k
equals zero, minimum here.
And you can put that at
a different point, OK?
And this curvature
gives me effective mass.
So if I say this is the energy
and expand this at the minimum,
then they are energy wave
[? actor ?] relation, right?
And here is my E
C the bottom here.
So energy [? wave ?] vector
relation is EC plus h bar k
square divide by 2 M star.
So h bar k we say, under this--
effective mass
concept, it's really
just like the 1/2 mv squared
because hk gives me momentum p.
p divided by mass gives me--
gives the velocity, right?
So that's the parabolic
band approximation.
And what we need
to keep in mind,
the k is a vector
in 3D space, right?
So kx we said, if we
in the x direction,
is 2 pi n times Lx, right?
And again, the end, if I
do all this parabolic band
approximation, my
[? zoom ?] boundary is here.
This is pi over ax, right?
[INAUDIBLE] x is how many
atoms times this appeared ax.
So let's say Lx equals n in
the x direction and periodicity
in the x direction, right?
That's how simple 1D model.
Just to make a comment, by
passing, now some of you
probably do work in graphene.
What's special with graphene
is that at the bottom here
the band here is not
quite a parabola.
It's actually a
straight line, OK?
So graphene the dispersion,
this is the energy.
This is wave vector.
And in small region
near the Fermi level,
right, it's a zero gap.
So the band gap
happened to be 0.
And so at the Fermi level,
the dispersion is linear.
And this linear
dispersion makes it
very similar to the
Debye model for phonon,
and also photon, right?
Photon is, if you think
about the model for photon,
is omega equals ck, right?
That's the speed of light.
And for phonons,
omega equals vk.
The v is the [? bi ?] velocity.
Sometimes we associate with the
[? sun's ?] velocity, right?
So that makes the
electron similar to photon
and similar to phonons.
So that's what's special
with the graphene.
So this is a kx, and of
course, I have a similar ky kz.
And k squared is a
combination of kx
squared plus ky squared
plus kz squared, OK?
So this means, my
constant energy surface,
if I give k is a constant.
Energy is a constant, right?
kx, ky, kz gives me a sphere.
So is a spherical, say,
constant energy surface.
Sometimes, if you draw
a real constant energy
surface in solid, it
look very complicated.
Sometimes, it look like a
ellipsoid or even other shapes,
OK?
But I'm doing the
simplest model.
And so what you can
[? say ?] is there
are many combination
of kx, ky, kz
that could give me
the same energy E.
And each combination
is one quantum state,
including a factor of 2, If.
I think about spin, right?
So this is the dispersion, the
energy with vector relation
is dispersion.
And for electrons
and for phonons,
we already said omega equals vk.
That's the [? bi ?]
approximation.
And k, now, that's the k for the
electron-- for the phonon wave
vector.
But again, based on
discussion we have,
those allowable values, right?
And for photon, omega equals
ck, like I just written down.
But say, this k, for photon,
I don't have a upper limit.
I haven't discussed--
so in free space,
this k could be
really large, OK?
So those are the dispersion
between frequency, wave vector,
or energy wave vector.
All those we call
dispersion relations, right?
Now, based on this, I'm going
to count how many states.
So it turns out, for
example, I want to count--
I have n electrons, right?
Where is the Fermi level?
If you recall, when I did the
simple one-dimensional hydrogen
atomic chain, right, and we
say this is the dispersion, OK?
And I have between
here, minus pi over A
to plus pi over A symmetric.
And I have k points,
I say, if it's a 1D,
I go to the lowest state.
And because I have n
states between minus pi
over a to plus pi over a.
I have n electrons, and
each of this wave function
have spin up spin done.
So I fill to the middle, right?
That's a 1D case.
Now, if I ask the same question
if it's a 3D, where does it go?
Where is the
[? finish, ?] right?
And in that case, because
there are many kx,
ky, kz combination, k gave
me the same energy level.
So I have to do this summation.
So this is the total
number of electrons.
Let's say total number of atoms.
If I say hydrogen, each hydrogen
give me one electron, right?
And then I have to
sum up what I know
is, let's say, [? they ?]
at zero temperature,
the lowest energy is
filled first, right?
So I have to think of
this now, rather than 1D,
I have to think about 3D, three
dimensional coordinate, right?
And you will fill to the
lowest and to the uppermost--
recall this is my Ef, right?
That's where my Fermi level is.
And the corresponding E, this
is my k if I say this is my kf,
OK?
And my model is xyz all
direction of the same,
if you look at what I
written down, right?
So kf-- so this is a [INAUDIBLE]
constant energy sphere
and the constant wave vector
also at that location.
So when they are--
so each of this
combination kx, ky,
kz gives me one quantum
state, as long as this quantum
state lies below Ef,
it has one electron.
So I add up the
total should give me
total number of n, total
number of electrons, OK?
And recall, this is
a huge lumber, right?
If I say one more, I've got
[INAUDIBLE] 10 to 23rd, OK?
It's going to be a very
large number summation.
So what I have
here is going to--
I say kx.
So any of those
allowable values below kf
or that kx value, right?
I have many points there.
I have ky, same.
I have kz, right?
As long as this kx squared
plus ky squared plus kz squared
is within this kf square, right?
So as long as it's
within this range,
all those combination give me
a quantum state that's filled,
right?
So I have each kx,
ky, discrete point,
kx, ky, kz gives me
one quantum state
except that doesn't count spin,
so I have a factor of 2, right?
So each of these quantum
state has one electron, right?
2 plus kx, ky, kz combination
is one electron, right?
Each of this--
So I really summed up
the one, one electron.
Do you get me?
I'm doing counting.
It's a basic counting, OK?
Now, if later on, I'm
not going to do one,
I'm going to do half filled.
At a certain temperature,
for example, some states
could be empty, right?
So I make, [? as ?] I
say, rather than one,
I may be a
[? probability-- ?] very soon,
at the end of lecture,
I hope I get there.
So this will be a function of
energy and chemical potential
and temperature, right?
Here, I'm doing my simplest
case at zero temperature,
any quantum state, we know
the Fermi level are filled,
and I have my requirement,
I have total n electrons.
And I want to find
out where is my kf.
Where's my Ef?
So now you go to do a summation.
How you do this
summation, right?
And doing a summation,
when it has many--
unless it's a simple series,
it's not easy, right?
So the way to do it is
to convert that summation
into an integration.
That's what we're
going to do next.
And the condition for
converting a summation
into integration, right, if I
have a function here, right?
And remember, this is a k,
each set of point is one value.
I'm summing up those values
when I do that summation, right?
And now, if this
function does not
vary rapidly between
the points, it's
like you do trapezoidal rule.
You can actually do convert
this sum back into integration.
So how we do it?
OK, let's say, kx, right?
If I have a delta kx, or d kx.
When I do integration,
I do a D kx, right?
So how many points
there are in D kx?
Now, I look at the spacing
between two adjacent points,
kx, 2 pi n Lx.
So what's the space in
between two adjacent point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
or x, right?
So I do d kx divided by 2 pi Lx.
That's how many
points over D kx, OK?
So now I'm converting
this one, and rather
than sum over, say, kx,
I do integration over--
this is my integration over kx.
So what's my limit?
If this is a kxf and
minus kxf, right?
So I have minus k fx plus k fx.
Remember, [? I ?]
mean symmetry, right?
Negative positive
k symmetric, OK?
And I do the same D ky
and 2 pi Ly kfy kfy,
and kfz kfz D kz 2 pi Lz.
And that integration is over 1.
But you probably don't like 1.
1 just to look
too [INAUDIBLE] So
let me just put any function,
as I said before, right?
Say, later on, I [? want to ?]
say the formula will come back
to F equals 1.
So the F as a function
of a E mu t, right?
And turns out, this f
could be any function.
Sometimes this f could be
a function of E. Sometimes
this could be a
function of k, OK?
And most of the time, when we do
a deal with density of states,
it's a function of E. So you
want [INAUDIBLE] function
of E or function of frequency.
But when you do transport--
I just want to warn you--
when you do transport,
this function
is often a function of k.
So the way I do the summation
sometimes in transport
is actually not very useful.
But it's such a so common
concept that's used.
Every time you go
to read or discuss,
people say what's your DOS.
What's the density
of states, OK?
So this is I'm converting that--
of course, I have a factor of 2.
I have my n.
This is the same.
I'm writing the summation
into integration.
And so now with this you
can say Lx, Ly, Lz gives me
volume, right, and 2 pi cubic.
So what I have is a
two volume 2 pi cubic.
And then say I have they
escape the integration limit.
And what I have here
is D kx, D ky, D kz.
Triple integral.
So by this transformation,
assuming this function
f does not change very rapidly
between adjacent point,
I have converted this
summation into integration.
And now, I have further
freedom because, you see here,
if I give you this
function f in terms of E,
E is a function of k, so you
have the freedom of how you
do integration, whether
you integrate in terms of E
or you integrate in terms of k,
you have to convert relating,
right?
Change into same variable so
you can do your integration.
And so what I can
do is, here, is
what I'm doing is in a
Cartesian coordinate,
D kx, D ky, D kz is a
Cartesian coordinate, right?
And if this is a
spherical symmetric.
So far, if it's a
function of a E,
you can say, if it's
a function of E,
it's spherical symmetric, right?
So if the function of E
formula, here, omega is k,
so it does not depend
on-- so in that case,
it's much easier if I do convert
the kx, ky, kz into just a k,
into a spherical
coordinate, right?
Rather than doing
triple integral,
I do just, say, D k, D x, D k--
if it's a twin spherical, if
this one is not a function,
it's only a function
of absolute value of k.
So this is 4 pi,
can you tell me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: K squared [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: K squared dk, right?
Try translating from a
Cartesian into spherical.
Everything [? out ?]
here is math.
But what's amazing is people--
this is such a [? convenient ?]
concept to talk about, right?
So here is the 4
pi k squared dk,
and then I can group
this together, OK?
Now I'm going to group this
back into here so that my--
I like to write n over
v. But many people--
so in that case, my density of
state [? is ?] per unit volume.
So here, n over v, then
is the integration.
And the F here, I combine
what ever all inside into--
you can say, I have pi
square k squared dk, right?
And so here, k is 0 to
kf, 0 kf, because I'm
doing spherical
coordinate, my radius is 0.
My kf-- I don't do
negative positive
because that's a
Cartesian coordinate.
You see what I'm doing?
OK?
So this one now is
my density of states.
This is a density
of states, so it's
a number of states per
unit interval of k, right?
How many states, quantum
state I have per delta k,
right, because here
I am [? say ?] in dk.
My integration is in dk.
So density of states in, if I
write it as in terms of k, that
means it's per delta k, OK?
But say, if you go back
to what I alluded here,
if my f is a function
of E, then you
have to make your choice whether
you want to convert E in this F
into k, or you want to convert
that dk into a function of E.
It's just your choice.
There is no formula there.
It's whatever is mathematically
convenient for you.
So I could also
convert, if I want
to convert into an energy
integration, so I will do Ef,
and f.
So in that case, I'll write this
into k squared pi square dk dE
and dE, right?
At the end, everything
in this blob,
I'm going to convert
rather in terms of E.
So I have a relation
between k and E. So I
can convert this k into E.
So if I write this in terms
of E, and I integrate over E,
this is my density of states
per energy interval, right?
Here's my number of
states per delta k.
Here is my density of
states per delta E. And say,
similarly, you can write it per
delta omega, or per delta neu,
or per delta lambda.
So with that, I
want to just say you
feel that it's a
mathematical concept,
and the key is can translate.
You can start from here.
You can write your summation
and go through that.
I've done that
probably 100 times,
so now I remember, when I
learned, I always go to book.
What's the formula
it gave in the book?
But if you get comfortable
with that summation,
it's translating summation
into integration.
And particularly, later on, when
we do like a Boltzmann equation
transport, this is going to
a function of kx, ky, kz.
So I do not actually do--
when I convert dkx, dky,
dkz, I do theta phi.
I do a spherical
coordinate, but I
don't have-- the function itself
do not have spherical symmetry.
So I will have to do,
in the general case,
this one, right, if I do
a spherical coordinate,
is psi theta, d theta, d
phi, dk, and k squared.
So this will be my
spherical converting
a unit volume in Cartesian into
a unit volume in spherical,
right?
But we're not doing that now.
When you do transport,
this is so common, OK?
OK, so that's the concept
of density of states.
And let's best use this
concept and do a few examples
to get familiar,
more comfortable.
So let's first look how they
continue our Fermi level,
right?
And I'm going to--
you can take, in
this case, it depends
on where you take your
reference, EC, right?
Here, if I write the
way I'm writing 0 to Ef,
integration is 0 to Ef.
I means 0 [INAUDIBLE]
starter equals 0.
So in that case I cannot use
EC because between 0 and EC,
there's no energy state.
Electron cannot fill
between 0 EC, right?
So you have to be careful
when you write those formulas
and use yourself consistently.
What's your reference?
Where you're doing
your integration?
Just a reminder.
And if I do--
following what I have here,
I have per unit volume.
I give you this
number of electrons.
And I want to find that either
absolute zero temperature.
Where is the upper most
energy level, right?
So my band then,
E equals h squared
k squared 2m, because of my
energy start [INAUDIBLE] start.
This is my E. This is my k.
I'm trying to find out
where is EF, right?
This is the Fermi level.
And so in that case, what I
have is F equals 1, right?
That's below the Fermi
level, all the energy,
each state is spin up spin down.
So I have n equals N
V equals 0 Ef and 1.
So the k square, so
what's my k square?
Now, I need to convert--
I want to convert into
E. This one is easy.
That's if I do in terms k.
But I want to do it in terms
of E, and so what I have,
k squared is 2M, right?
So k equals 2M star E
over h bar squared 1/2
based on the dispersion.
So I have to k squared is
2M star E h bar squared.
That's my k squared pi square.
So I will put a pi square here.
And then I have my dk dE, dk dE.
This is my k.
This is my E. So my
dk dE is a 1/2 2M
star h bar square, and
dk dE, this is a 1/2
and E negative 1/2.
So this is an overall
integrate over dE.
Now, I'm going to erase this.
So what I've written down is
really what's the inside this .
I convert a k into
E. I convert dk dE.
I'll write it also in terms
of E so that at the end
I have all that blob is my
density of state, right?
So here is what's
my density of state.
You say 2M h bar squared.
That's 3/2.
And the E and the E minus 1/2,
so my density of states is--
you fill-- I just want to
check everything is written--
It should be correct, OK?
So what I have
here is 2pi square
and M star 2M over h bar squared
and 3/2 and E minus E 1/2.
So this is my density of states.
And this E is referring to
my 0 is at the bottom, EC.
If I take my 0 at a
different location,
I have to do E minus EC, OK?
So many times, when I
was just learning this,
I just say, OK, I forgot it.
I went to the book.
I do a derivation,
and then I plug
in here because, at the end,
you want to do this f times dE
and integrate over [? energy. ?]
But I say, now I can
comfortably sit there,
and every time I
forget, I say, I
redo my summation to
integration conversion, OK?
It takes many times.
So that's the density
of states, right?
And of course, now I
want to find out that
where is Ef, right?
So here, if you say
this is your Ef,
you put it in this density
of states, it's [? dEd ?] dE,
right?
Essentially, what I
have here is 0 Ef dE dE.
Many times people
get familiar, this is
where they [? start, ?] right?
I want to find out where is Ef.
Give me the number electron.
I write density of state.
I integrate over E. That's
how many states I have, right?
Each state I have one electron.
So that's how many
electron I have.
And with that, you go
to do your integration.
You say, this is a
constant you can take out.
It's really E 1/2 integration
over dE and to 0 to Ef, right?
So this will give you
where the Fermi level--
you do your integration.
You find out that your Ef
equals 3 pi square n 2/3
n h bar square 2M.
That's after you do your
integration and the inverse
writing in terms of Ef.
OK, any question here?
It's converting summation
into integration.
Do the correct accounting.
The density of states
tells you the number
of quantum state per energy
interval, per wave vector
interval, per
frequency interval.
Many ways to write it, OK?
So that's [? electron. ?]
And just a comment, right?
Let me draw the density
of state for electron.
This is an energy.
This is DE, right?
And if I have an energy
[INAUDIBLE] to the EC,
this is E minus EC.
So I put my EC not at 0,
but at an arbitrary point.
Then this is the problem,
density of state.
That's the shape
of density of state
because it's square root, OK?
That's because, if
you say at the bottom,
there are not many states.
But you increase energy,
there are a lot more states
that have same energy values.
OK, so now let's
do the same phonon.
Conceptually, we follow
the same process,
converting this summation
into integration.
OK, so I'm going to
look at the phonon.
And I'm using Debye model.
And Debye model say
omega equals v times k,
and this k is the magnitude
of the wave vector, right?
So it's a square root of
kx squared plus ky squared
plus kz squared.
And also, in this case,
the phonons are degenerate.
Three polarizations transfers
to longitudinal one.
In Debye, it just
collapse the other three
into one line there.
But you should still there
are three polarizations, OK?
So in that case, if you go back
to, starting from my summation,
whatever function,
right, and let's
forget about what I'm going to
integrate because right now I
don't have a good stuff
[INAUDIBLE] for you yet.
We need to go to the
strategical distribution
to actually give you
f, for example, right?
So I can word that summation
into integration, same.
But they have factor of 2,
which is spin for electron,
need to become a factor of 3
because I have a polarization.
Debye model, I have three
polarization, right?
OK, for each kx, ky, kz I
have three polarization,
so I have three--
that's where my factor of 3.
So if you look at
my dk, that's--
where is my dk here.
This is my density of state dk.
Before it's a factor of 2.
Now the factor of 3, so that
should be a 3/2 of this.
So my dk density of
states for phonon, is 3/2.
What I have here is a k
square pi square, right?
Now, my d omega is dk
and the deck dk d omega.
So this is a
[? rate that ?] eventually
it has to be changed into--
k has to be changed
into omega, right?
Now I'm going to do
frequency integration.
Phonon I normally don't do dE.
My habit is,
typically, do d omega.
Now I do dk d omega, right?
So dk d omega, so dk is
3/2 k is omega over v here
square pi square.
And dk d omega is
1 over v, right?
OK, so with that, I will get
the 3/2 pi square v cubic omega
square.
So this is density
of states for phonon.
And here is d omega,
and here is omega.
So it's a parabola.
It's not square root.
Density of states for electron
is the square root of energy,
right?
Here is actually
square of energy, OK?
So different dispersion give
you different density of states.
Now, this could be easily
convert into photon.
Photon now allow longitudinal
electromagnetic waves, right?
Only two polarization,
two transverse waves, OK?
And that two transverse
waves should not be three.
It should be two.
And the speed of sound
becomes speed of light, right?
So for photon density of
state, in terms of frequency,
is just omega squared
pi square C cubic, OK?
The [? best ?] is so you
[? see ?] there and [? write ?]
through all this, right,
getting yourself comfortable.
It's mathematics.
It's really not much physics.
OK, so that's the
case of 3D structure.
Now, let's do a 2D.
I'm doing-- OK, so we say,
let's look at the quantum well.
Let's look at a thin film.
What will be the
quantization effect
on the density of states, OK?
So let's do a 2D.
I'm putting it here.
This is the best place.
I'm going to do a quantum well.
OK, before when we talk
about quantum well,
we say just a
one-dimensional quantum well.
Now, I'm going to give you
more realistic a feel, right?
In the case of [? film, ?]
electron can move in xyz
three dimension.
And so if I have a film, and
in the thickness direction
I have Lz, OK?
And in the xy direction
I have free motion.
I don't have
constraint, all right?
So my energy relation
would be kx, ky.
In the xy direction,
I have discrete point
as what we had before, but say
that 2 pi Lx, 2 pi Ly, right?
That's my separation.
But my Lx Ly in the xy direction
are millimeters, right?
That's a macroscopic.
So that separation
is a very small.
In the z direction, I'm
Angstrom's, [? Henry ?]
Angstrom, right?
So in that case,
recall that when
we discuss the energy in this
direction, is standing wave,
right?
So n z-- let me just use n.
Lambda over 2 equals Lz, right?
And that means lambda
equals Lz 2 divided by n.
And you can convert this
back into energy, right?
Say, the momentum k
equals 2 pi over lambda.
And what you have here?
2 pi over lambda.
Lambda is there, so I have
[? n ?] pi over Lz, right?
And the separation between--
this is my k in the z direction.
Separation is become pi over Lz.
Now, if you look
at the separation,
we say, in the unconstrained
case, kx 2 pi Lx over n, right?
So in the unconstrained
case, I have plus minus.
And the separation
is a 2 pi over Lx.
In the constraint case, I
have n is only plus, OK?
And the separation
is pi over Lz.
It's a factor of two difference.
That's because I'm
using a traveling wave.
This is traveling wave,
positive and negative direction,
to construct a
standing wave, right?
So it's actually equivalent.
Whether I use plus minus
in the case or whether I
use standing wave.
But in the case of
small length, Lz,
I have to look at the separation
because that summation cannot
be converted into integration.
So this is the difference.
So if I write, in that case,
I write my energy is h square,
say, kx squared plus ky square,
that's in [? there. ?] So
[? effective ?] mass in the
[? implant ?] direction,
in the xy direction, OK?
And in the z direction,
if I use this,
I can do my energy
quantization, right?
It's hk divided by hk squared
divided by [? 2M. ?] So 1/2 M
hk square, h square.
k squared is M pi
over Lz square, right?
n equals 1, 2, OK?
So this is my energy level.
I'm still writing h square,
kz square. k squared, now,
I do a standing wave.
And because my Lz
is very small, so
between the two
constructive n, there
[? could ?] be many kx ky, OK?
So if you look at this, what
I have here, recall, in a 3D,
right, a spherical,
let's say, we [? see ?]
a constant energy surface
is a sphere, right?
Now, I have a constant
energy surface,
is an xy [? plane ?]
is a circle,
but then depends on the
n value I have jumps
different values, OK?
It depends on the
different energy.
So the other way to think
about this, n equals 1.
So this is where we draw
quantization [? fact. ?]
This is EC before.
That's [? a bulk, ?] right?
That's a [? bulk. ?]
Of course, I'm
only drawing one direction, OK?
But you have to think that
this as a-- kx ky is like
so you do a rotation, right?
So here.
And when I have
quantization, it turns out
that the minimum energy
now can no longer be here
because equals 1.
That gives me the
first level, right?
So the bottom of
the conduction band
actually will shift up, right?
So that's why sometimes people
say, how I can open a gap?
When I have quantization,
I can artificially
turn even a [? semi ?]
metal into a semiconductor.
Let me give you one idea.
For example, when work on
[? thermal ?] electrics,
there is a material, bismuth.
Turns out, bismuth
is like this, right?
It's a [? semi ?] metal.
There is no gap.
This is the top of
valence, bottom conduction,
and conduction band
is below valence band.
So in [? this, ?] the
Fermi level is around here,
and there's no gap.
It's a [? semi ?] metal, right?
[? Semi ?] metal is not good
for thermal electrics
because when electron in this
[INAUDIBLE] in this, you can
still have electron holes.
And when they diffuse
to the same direction,
the [? heat ?]
cancel each other.
So it's not good.
So how we can create a band
gap out of this material?
And you do a size effect.
So you make it smaller, and
theoretically, what happens
is this one is a function
of a diameter or thickness.
So this will move up.
Depends on thickness.
This one will move down, right?
So now you can create a gap.
And there are also discussion,
for example, with silicon,
right?
Silicon is like what
do you have here?
This is the indirect gap.
The valence band is here,
conduction band is here, right?
There is another conduction
band, but it's not the minimum.
This is the minimum.
So now what do you do?
You make a very
small [INAUDIBLE],,
and this will move up.
Of course, this will move down.
And this will also move.
Depends on the speed of moving.
That relates to the mass, right?
And this could be move to here,
and this one moves slower.
So this you can convert
it into direct gap, OK?
So that's the beauty of this.
Think about this
quantum size effect.
You can use that to tune the
band gap of the materials.
And that's when you make,
say, like quantum dots,
like [? cat ?] [INAUDIBLE] or
[? cat ?] sulfite, [INAUDIBLE]
[? cat ?] sulfite.
Or if you look at Professor
[INAUDIBLE] website,
he has all these beautiful
dots, different colors.
And that's because the same
material you change the size,
you can actually open,
make a different gap, OK?
So [? those ?] are digression.
I'll come back to--
I want to find out what the
density of state, right?
So let me, again, start
with, OK, I have here
is a number of electrons.
I gave to this.
How many electron
in the material.
And I still do my kx ky, my kz,
my F, whatever F I have there,
function that I'm interested
in integrating, right?
And in 3D, I said this F is a
very slow function of kx, ky,
kz, so I convert it
into integration.
But in 2D, in the z direction,
between two consecutive--
so this is EC, and my
first energy level is here.
My second energy level is here.
Between these two,
there are many kx ky.
There are many states
in between kx ky, right?
So I cannot convert in the z
direction into a summation--
into integration.
I need to keep that
summation, and what I could do
is only convert the xy
direction into integration.
So this is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to keep
my, say, summation.
In the x direction,
I can still do.
So I have dkx 2 pi Lx.
And y direction, I
still do dky 2 pi Ly.
In z direction, I cannot do.
I'm going to keep my summation.
And rather than kz,
I can also do n.
It's equivalent whether you do n
notation or kz notation, right?
And whatever F. I have a factor
of 2M over the inside, right?
So now, rather than do
3D Cartesian coordinate,
your mathematics is in
2D, kx ky integration.
So you do either
polar coordinate,
or so it depends on what's
your F. F is a function of E,
or it's-- right?
So that's your choice.
I'm going to do, here, you
see I have area Lx times Ly.
And if I do d kx,
d ky, I convert it
into a polar coordinate.
d kx d ky in polar--
if it's a symmetric,
it's 2 pi k dk, right?
Let's say, k--
I just make a notation kx
squared plus ky square.
So it's 2D, k parallel.
So in this case, I have 2
pi k parallel dk parallel.
And that's the dkx dky.
And then I have 2 pi square.
That's here, 2 pi square.
Then I have another
2 summation n F, OK?
See, I'm not the [? jumping ?]
into density of states.
I'm deriving density of states.
I'm comfortable doing that,
the concept of just converting
my summation into integration.
And what I can do,
my F is energy.
So I can write my k parallel
also in terms of energy.
So now let's go back
to the dispersion.
Let's say this-- let me make a
notation this is my En, right?
That's the sublevels of
quantized in z direction.
And this is my k
parallel square.
So I can write this--
my k parallel squared
equals 2M star h bar
square E minus En, right?
So I have, really, you can
say here, I need to convert--
if I want to write
it in terms of dE,
I need to convert this
k parallel into energy.
And I need a dk parallel dE, OK?
So if you do your
math, if you go
to look at what we have
there, what I have is--
so this is a 2 pi times
1, and 2 cancels 1.
I have another pi, right?
So I have integration 1 over
pi and sigma whatever n F.
And now I need to
write here k parallel.
In fact, if I put this in, I do
the dk square, parallel square
because dk parallel
square I have here, right?
So I have a dk parallel squared.
That means I have 1/2.
I have 2 m bar star
and h square and dE.
I'm not sure whether you're
following my conversion.
I'm writing this into E.
k parallel [INAUDIBLE]
based on what I have here.
And of course, I
have a summation n.
That means, when E--
E has to be larger
than En, right?
Otherwise, this is a, ,
you can say, if it's E,
it's less than En, my k parallel
will be [? measured, ?] OK.
So what I have here,
all this blob, blob F. F
is the one that I
want to integrate.
My density of states is--
this cancel, En and
M star and h square.
And I have another pi, and
that's my density of state, OK?
It's a step function.
n equals 1, n equals 2.
You add another one. n equals 3.
You had another one, right?
So what I have here
is, if I draw--
this is my E, and say I have--
and this is my E1, E2.
That's the quantization
energy level.
E3 is a step function.
And before we draw the electron,
you go check your loads.
This is a parabola, right?
This is like EC.
That's a 3D.
This is 2D.
So you see now
[? they're ?] difference
in density of states.
And once you go
to quantized mode,
you got a more sharp
features, right?
Step function, and you
go to [? wire. ?] You
got actually some
delta function, dots.
You got a delta function.
It's this kind of
step and delta,
or line that give you some
very peculiar characteristics
for the quantum systems, OK?
Any questions.
It's mass, OK?
It's counting.
No complicated physics.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: In your sum, your
n is restricted, right?
So you have [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the
right way to write it is I
write a [? heavy ?]
side function.
So [? heavy ?] side is
a step function, OK?
OK, so we spend most of today's
lecture in doing the counting.
And I say how I-- really,
it's converting summation
into integration.
And if the function doesn't
change much over the summation,
I can convert.
In the quantums case, in the
direction of quantization,
that conversion is usually
have to be careful.
You probably cannot do that
conversion because there is
a large change of that function
in the summation direction.
And what we're going
next is do this f.
In particular,
we're doing a system
at a certain
temperature, and what's
the answer to the question at
one quantum state, each quantum
state.
For example, what's the
average number of electron,
because it could be 0 or 1.
But at a certain temperature,
there is statistical average.
What's that number?
The same for phonon, right?
I can have 0, 1, infinite.
Then what's the average number
of phonon for each quantum
state?
Now, I know how I can
count quantum state, right?
How many quantum states I have?
What I want to say next
is, at each quantum
state, how many electrons?
How many phonons given
a certain temperature?
And I'm going to get into
a thermal system, right?
And how much energy you have?
So let me give a very--
say a beginning of that, and in
fact, if you recall, we did--
in the first chapter, we give
you the Boltzmann factor,
right?
So this is my
quantum statistics.
And in the first
chapter beginning
we say the Boltzmann
factor gives you
the probability of a particle.
We were not discussing whether
it's quantum or classical.
Probability of particle
having certain energy
at certain temperature is a
normalization factor minus,
say, exponential E [? kdT. ?]
I said take it.
This is the Boltzmann
factor, right?
And you've seen many, many
examples of this Boltzmann
factor.
Say, the energy
barriers, [INAUDIBLE]..
All this is related to
the Boltzmann factor.
And next lecture I hope I give
you a little bit of rationale
on this, OK?
There is a beautiful statistical
framework to do that.
And say we use this, and
then we went to the Maxwell
distribution, right?
If I have [? particle ?]
that has energy
1/2 M vx squared plus vy
squared plus vz square, right?
I say, OK, I normalize this.
I put it in here,
and the a particle
has the probability
between minus infinite
and positive infinite is what?
So with that, I find that
[? a, ?] normalization factor.
That's how I get the
Maxwell distribution, right?
So you see, in that
process, I did not
consider the discontinuity
of the velocity,
any value between minus
infinite to plus infinite.
Now, I'm going to do a little
bit of say discontinuous,
right?
I'm going to ask you, for
example, if I have a quantum
state, electron is in thermal
equilibrium with surrounding
at a temperature T, right?
And electron, say,
what's the average--
so this is a now I'm looking
at one quantum state, right?
It's in thermal equilibrium
with surrounding.
I'm asking question, what's
the probability of this quantum
state, how many
electron it has, right?
So that's a question I'm asking,
and now, the difference of that
question, there are two
difference compared to here.
One is that, electron in that
quantum state, it can go.
The electron can be
in that quantum state
or jump out into
the surrounding.
So I have mass transfer, charge
transfer, whatever, right?
It's an open system.
So that's one.
Second is that electron
in that quantum state
can only have 0 and
1, discrete, OK?
So when I have here,
Boltzmann factor
is a [? foreclosed ?] system
at constant temperature.
And the [? one ?]
ideal is an open system
at a constant temperature,
I have to modify this.
So I'm going to
give you, again--
just wait for the next lecture--
say, the Gibbs factor.
And Gibbs factor
is for open system.
And the probability of
a system, open system,
has a certain energy and
certain number of particle
is at temperature T is A, again,
normalization minus the energy
of the system minus
the number of particle
times this constant
mu and divide by kBT.
So now, I add this mu, which
is the chemical potential.
That's to say how much energy
you need to take out or place
a particle into the system.
That's the chemical
potential, OK?
So mu is the chemical potential.
And that's the same chemical
potential is, essentially,
the Gibbs free energy.
And it doesn't include
the entropy part,
and Gibbs free energy
difference gives
you how much work you can
get out of the system, OK?
So with that, I'm considering
one isolated electron quantum
state.
This is the easiest.
So I have one quantum
state of electron, right?
This is the solution you
had before in quantum--
either for solid or for a
molecule or for atom, right?
You have the solution
of quantum state.
This is what we've been doing.
The question is whether there
is the electron in the quantum
state or not.
So what's the probability?
is it 0 or [? 1, ?] right?
Well, say, these
are the two states.
When n equals 0 or
1, when n equals 0,
even though you have
the quantum state,
that state doesn't have
real electron pair,
doesn't have energy.
So the energy when
this is 0, this is 0.
And when you have one
particle that energy,
that state has energy Ei, right?
So Ei.
Now, I use this,
two possibility.
I do my normalization
factor for the Gibbs factor.
So add up, it has to be
either 0 or [? 1, ?] right?
They add [? up ?]
[? who has ?] to be what?
So when it's 0, p
0 0 T, plus p here
is Ei 1 T. That has to be 1.
So the first, when 0 0,
that's just A. The second one,
Ei, so I have minus Ei.
Mu times n is just
mu kBT equals 1.
So this gives me A
equals exponential
minus Ei minus mu kBT plus 1.
That's my normalization
factor, A, right?
Now, my average
number of particle F,
average number, which is the
average number of n, right?
Once I have distribution
probability,
I can find the average, any
quantity, average energy,
average number of particle,
whatever average you want,
right?
So that should be 0 because
0 times this p 0 0 T plus 1.
I have one particle
times p Ei 1 T. So
that's my average
number of particle,
right, because this is the
probability when Ei 1 fully
empty.
And you go-- you know
your A. You know your p--
A time this, Ei mu n.
So you can say this one and
this one is the same, right?
In the numerator,
I have this one.
In the denominator,
I have this one,
but I have a plus
factor 1, right?
So I derive this so I
can write a simpler--
and you will see now what I
have is Ei minus mu kBT plus 1.
And this is the famous
Fermi-Dirac distribution, OK?
So in three steps, right, if you
take that energy conversation,
probably normalization,
you got a Fermi-Dirac.
And the next lecture
we'll go a few more steps,
put it together, Bose-Einstein
distribution for phonons.
This is for electrons.